♪
>> WELCOME TO THE SPECIAL YATION
OF HANTY.
TONIGHT WE BEGIN AT THE WHITE
HOUSE WHERE PRESIDENT BIDESON
RECOVERING FROM A LONG TRIP
ABROAD NOTICEABLY MISSING FROM
JOE'S WORLD TOUR, HIS SON,
HUNTER.  ONCE A FIXTURE ON HIS
FATHER'S OFFICIAL VISITS THE
BIDEN FAMILY'S BAG MAN IS NOW
LAYING LOW.
REPUBLICANS ARE POISED TO TAKE
CONTROL OF THE HOUSE, AND THE
ADMINISTRATION IS IN MANIC MODE.
TONIGHT, THE EVIDENCE IS
OVERWHELMING.  FOR YEARS THE
BIDEN FAMILY ENRICH THEMSELVES
BY SELLING ACCESS TO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.  TO SKETCHY FOREIGN
NATIONALS ALL OVER THE WORLD.
NOT ONLY DID JOE BIDEN
REPORTEDLY PARTICIPATE IN THESE
ELICIT DEALS, BUT HE ALSO LIED
ABOUT IT OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
NOW, IN AN EFFORT TO MUDDY THE
UPCOMING HOUSE PRO BIDEN'S
ALLIES ARE PLANNING A
MULTIMILLION DOLLAR SMEAR CAM
FINE PERSONALLY ATTACK ANYONE
PARTICIPATING IN THE HOUSE
INVESTIGATION.
HERE NOW WITH THE VERY LATEST
FOX NEW LEGAL ANALYST GREG
JARRETT AND FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR
JOE CON CHA.
JOE, I WANT TO KNOW TO YOU
FIRST, BECAUSE MY FORMER
COLLEAGUE HE LIKED TO SAY THE
WAY THE MEDIA TREATS THIS THEY
NEVER SAW A REPUBLICAN
INVESTIGATION THEY EVER THOUGHT
WAS JUSTIFIED AND THEY NEVER SAW
A DEMOCRATIC INVESTIGATION THEY
EVER THOUGHT SHOULD END.
IT'S ALMOST PREDICTABLE ON HOW
THEY'RE GOING TO TREAT ANY
INVESTIGATION INTO HUNTER BIDEN
AND JOE BIDEN FOR THAT MATTER?
>> OH, MY.
I MEAN, JASON, FOR EVERYONE WHO
DID AN END ZONE DANCE AROUND
DEMOCRATS ONLY LOSING THE HOUSE
BY A TOUCHDOWN INSTEAD OF THREE
TOUCHDOWNS, A WIN IS A WIN IN
THE END.  WHEN THE NEW CONGRESS
IS SWORN IN IN TWO MONTHS WE'RE
GOING TO SO WHAT A WIN LOOKS
LIKE FOR THE REPUBLICAN PART Y
REGARDLESS OF THE MARGIN.
MANY IN THE MEDIA CAN DOWNDOWN
PLAY i THIS ALL THEY LIKE JUST
LIKE THEY DID THE MINUTER BIDEN
LAPTOP STORY IN 2020 IN CALLING
IT RUSSIAN DISINFORMATION.
BOY, THAT LOOKS FOOLISH IN,
DOESN'T IT?  THE MINUTER BIDEN
STORY IS A HUGE STORY,
POTENTIALLY THE BIGGEST STORY OF
THE BIDEN PRESIDENCY.  THAT'S
NOT HYPERBOLE BECAUSE IF, AND
THIS NEEDS TO BE PROVEN BEYOND
THE SHOULD SO OF THE DOUBT, IF
THE SITTING PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES PROFITED ON THE
SHADY DEALS HIS SON CONDUCTED
PARTICULARLY IN CHINA -- BY THE
WAY, HUNTER BIDEN'S BUSINESS
PARTNER HAS ALLEGED SUCH.  WE
MAY HAVE A PRESIDENT WHO IS
CURRENTLY COMPROMISED BY OUR
BIGGEST ADVERSARY, YET MANY IN
MEDIA ARE NOT ONLY MISSING THE
COURTESY GENE THAT SO MEN
JOURNALISTS SHOULD HAVE IN ANY
STORY WITH THIS MUCH EVIDENCE,
COURTESY OF THAT LAPTOP FROM
HELL.
THOSE E-MAILS ARE REAL.
EVERYBODY'S VERIFIED IT.
THEY SEEK TO DISMISS THIS AND
SUPPRESS IT JUST LIKE THEY
DINNED OCT OF 2020.
AND LOOK, THE FACTS ARE THE
FACTS AND WE'RE GOING TO GET TO
THE FACTS NOW THAT WE HAVE A
CONGRESS THAT ACTUALLY
INTERESTED IN GETTING TO THE
FACTS.
JEAN, GREG.
THINGS ARE GOING TO CHANGE
BECAUSE NOON STED OF BEING
CONGRESSMAN JIM YOR MEANS.
GOING TO BE CHAIRMAN JORDAN AND
JAMES COMBER WILL HAVE THE SAME
PRIVILEGES AND HONORS THAT I HAD
WHEN I WAS THE CHAIRMAN OF THE
OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE.
I GOTTA TELL YOU WHAT I THINK IT
BIG CHALLENGE OUT THERE WILL
THEY WITH THE SAME VORACITY
PURSUE THESE SUPINES THAT ARE
GOING TO BE ISSUES BY THESE TWO
CHAIRMEN AND WILL THEY PROSECUTE
PEOPLE WHO DON'T SHOW UP OR
WHERE THERE IS ENDIVE DON
CRIMINAL MISCHIEF.
>> NO, I DON'T THINK THEY WILL.
I THINK THE RECORD IS
WELL-ESTABLISHED THAT MERRICK
GARLAND HAS BEEN RUNNING A
PROTECTION RACKET FOR JOE AND
HUNTER BIDEN.
HOW ELSE DO YOU EXPLAIN A FOUR
AND A HALF YESTER YEAR
INVESTIGATION THAT APPEARS TO
HAVE GONE NOWHERE IN TERMS OF
ANY CHARGE FILED.
AND AS YOU KNOW AS A FORMER
MEMBER OF CONGRESS, ANY SUBPOENA
ISSUED BY THE JOBE SIGHT
COMMITTEE IS A MEANINGLESS SCRAP
OF PAPER.
THEY CANNOT ENFORCE IT
THEMSELVES.  IT HAS TO BE DONE
BY THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
OVER WITH WHICH MERRICK GARLAND
PRESIDES.
YOU KNOW, SO, NO MISTAKE ABOUT
IT, THIS IS A 31-ENERGYEM REPORT
BY REPUBLICANS ON THE OVERSIGHT
COMMITTEE IT IS CHALK FULL OF
EVIDENCE OF FRAUD, BRIBERY,
INFLUENCE PEDALING, VIOLATIONS
OF THE FOREIGN CORRUPT PRACTICES
ACT, SELF-ENRICHMENT.
AND YET, THERE HAVE BEEN NO
CHARGES.
I THINK WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN
IS THAT MERRICK GARLAND WELL NOT
ENFORCE THESE SUPINES AND HE'LL
SAY I CAN'T DO IT BECAUSE YOU
KNOW OUR INVESTIGATION INTO JOE
AND HUNTER BIDEN IS STILL AN
GOING.
BUT THIS REPORT MAKES IT
ABUNDANTLY CLEAR THAT FOREIGN
GOVERNMENTS AND ENTITIES WERE
PAYING TENS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS TO THE BIDEN FAMILY AND
HUNTER BIDEN'S BUSINESSES REMAKE
IN ROMANIA, KAZAKHSTAN, UKRAINE,
RUSSIA, CHINA IN PARTICULAR,
MORE THAN A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS FLOWING IN TO THE BIDEN
COUGHERS.
YOU KNOW, IT'S GOING TO BE VERY
VERY DIFFICULT FOR THE OVERSIGHT
COMMITTEE TO GET TO THE BOTTOM
OF THE LIS UNLESS THEY CAN GET
SUBPOENA POWER THAT IS
ENFORCEDDABLE.
>> YEAH, AND ALONG WITH THAT,
NUT ONLY DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
WE'LL SEE HOW THEY REACT BECAUSE
HOW THEY TREATED THE DEMOCRATS
SHOULD BE THE PRECEDENT, BUT I
JUST, I CAN'T IMANNAL AN THAT
THEY'RE GOING GOING TO HAVE THE
SAME SORT OF SPEED AND DRIVE TAT
THEY DID WHEN NANCY PELOSI HAD
THE GAVEL.
JOE, ONE OF THE THINGS THAT'S
ALSO KNOWING TO CHANGE AND THE
DEMOCRATS HAVE TELEGRAPHED THIS,
THEY'RE STARTING THISAWAY ROOM.
THEY ARE LITERALLY GOING TO POOR
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS TO GO IN AND
ATTACK AND GO AFTER MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS TRYING TO DO THEIR
SO-CALLED FACT-CHECKING IN
REAL-TIME.
WHEN I WAS CHAIRMAN OF THE
OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE I DIDN'T
FACE THAT.
I FACED A LOT OF THINGS BUT NOT
THIS PRE-ANNOUNCED WAR ROOM
WHERE THEY'RE GOING TO GO AFTER
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS.
THAT'S UNPRECEDENTED IN MY BOOK.
>> IT IS COMPLETELY.
AND SOCIAL MEDIA HELPS DRIVE
THAT.
YOU CREATE THIS ILLUSION THAT
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE
ABSOLUTELY AGAINST ANY
INVESTIGATION INTO THE
PRESIDENT'S SON, BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY INTO HIS BROTHER.
THE REAL TEST NOW, JASON, IS
WILL ABCISHN BC, CNS, MSNBC, PBS
ASK BASICALLY EVERY BROADCAST
NEWS STATION IN THIS COUNTRY,
WELL THE COVER THE HUNTER BIDEN
HEARINGS WITH THE SAME VIGOR,
THE SAME PASSION THAT WE SAW
WITH THE JANUARY 6TH HEARINGS
WHERE, EVERY REMEMBER, ALL
BROADCASTING WAS PREEMPTED AS A
RESULT OF THOSE HEARINGS THAT
WERE PRODUCED BY FORMER
PRESIDENT OF ABC NEWS.
SO, LOOK, THE SAME HEARINGS BY
THE WAY JANUARY 6TH DID NOT LOU
FOR ANY CROSS-EXAM NATION IN
THOSE PARTICULAR HEARINGS AND IT
WAS PATENTLY PARTISAN.  WE ALL
SAW THAT IN BROAD DAYLIGHT.
SO LOOK, THESE HEARINGS AROUND
HUNTER BIDEN WILL BE DISMISSED,
MACKED RIDICULED BY THE VERY
PEOPLE WHO SAID YOU SHOULD TAKE
THE JANUARY 6TH HEARINGS AS
SERIOUSLY AS A HEART ATTACK.
Y.
BIUS IN BROAD DAYLIGHT.
I THINK THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
GIVEN THE EVIDENCE, GIVEN ALL
THOSE THINGS THAT ARE ON PAPER,
ALL THOSE WIRE TRANSFERS, BANK
FRANZS, AFTER A WHILE WHEN THEY
START TO HEAR THIS IN OTHER
PLACES BESIDES TRADITIONAL MEDIA
THEY'LL BE DEMANDING ANSWERS
BECAUSE THIS COULD BE A SITTING
PRESIDENT THAT IS COMPROMISE BY
THE LIKES OF CHINA A, UKRAINE,
AND ALL THE OTHER COUNTRIES THAT
GREG JUST LISTED.
>> GREG, PRESIDENT TRUMP SPOKE
LESS THAN AN HOUR AGO AND HE WAS
ASKING THE QUESTION, HOW COME
THERE'S, IF THEY'RE GOING DO A
SPECIAL PROSECUTOR ON DONALD
TRUMP, HOW COME THEY'RE NOT
GOING TO BE DOING A SPECIAL
PROSECUTOR WITH THE CONFLICTS OF
INTEREST THAT THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL HAS.
LISTEN AND WATCH HERE TO WHAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP JUST SAID A FEW
MINUTES AGO.
>> THE CORRUPT AND HIGHLY
POLITICAL JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
JUST APPOINTED A SUPER RADICAL
LEFT SPECIAL COUNSEL, BETTOR
REFERRED TO AS SPECIAL
PROSECUTOR TO START THE PROCESS
ALL OVER AGAIN.
WE THAT IT WAS JUST ABOUT DEAD.
JOE BIDEN IS A CORRUPT AND
INCOMPETENT POLITICAL HACK.
YOU TAKE A LOOK AT ALL OF THE
MONEY THAT HE'S TAKEN FROM FOR
FOREIGN COUNTRIES AND MUCH OF IT
THROUGH HIS SON, HUNTER WHO IS A
CORRUPT DRUG ADDICT AND
IMPLEMENTER FOR HIS FATHER,
WHERE'S THEIR SPECIAL
PROSECUTOR, BY THE WAY?
>> YEAH.
GREG, YOUR REACTION TO WHAT THE
PRESIDENT SAID?
>> WELL, HE'S A HUNDRED PERCENT
CORRECT.
ES.
LUDICROUS TO THE POINT OF BEING
LAUGHABLE FOR MERRICK GARLAND TO
STAND THERE AND SIGHT A CONFLICT
OF INTEREST THAT MERITS THE
APPOINTMENT OF A SPECIAL COUNCIL
TO INVESTIGATION TRUMP.
WHILE AT THE SAME TIME THERE IS
A FAR GREATER CONFLICT OF
INTEREST THAT DEMANDS AND IT'S
MANDATORY UNDER THE SPECIAL
COUNCIL STATUTE FOR GARLAND TO
APPOINT A SPECIAL COUNCIL TO
INVESTIGATE HUNTER AND JOE
BIDEN.
WOULD --
WHAT ALSO CONCERNS ME IS THAT A
SPECIAL COUNCIL UNDER THE
REGULATIONS IS SUPPOSED TO BE
IMPARTIAL, AND OUTSIDE THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
THIS NAMED SPECIAL COUNCIL IS
FAR FROM IMPARTIAL AND NEUTRAL.
HE SERVED IN THE DOJ DURING TWO
DEMOCRAT ADMINISTRATIONS.
HE'S CLEARLY BIAS POLITICALLY.
AND HE'S BARELY OUT OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE WHERE HE
SPENT MOST OF HIS CAREER.
I AM WORRIED THAT THIS IS
SHAPING P TO BE JUST LIKE THE
ANDREW WEISMAN BOB MULLER
SPECIAL COUNCIL PARTISAN TEAM OF
PROSECUTORS THAT ARE KNOWING TO
GO AFTER DONALD TRUMP WITH A
VENGEANCE AND NOT BE FAIR AS THE
SPECIAL COUNCIL STATUTE DEMANDS.
>> WHAT A COINCIDENCE, THEY
NAMED A SPECIAL PROSECUTOR DAYS
AFTER DONALD TRUMP SUGGESTED HE
DECLARES HE'S GOING TO RUN IF
PRESIDENT AND JUST AFTER THE
REPUBLICANS GAIN CONTROL OF THE
HOUSE.
WHAT A COINCIDENCE.  IT'S JUST,
IT'S ALMOST EMBARE ESING THAT --
>> --
>> YEAH, AND YOU LOOK AT THIS
BACKGROUND I THINK YOU'RE GOING
TO HEAR LOT MORE ABOUT THIS
SO-CALLED INDEPENDENCE OF THE
SPECIAL CAUGHT PROSECUTOR.
LOOK AT HIS RUN-INS IN HIS
PROXIMITY TO LOIS LEARNER IN
THAT INVESTIGATION THAT THE
HOUSE IS INVOLVED WITH.